do you think that food that contains DNA
should be labeled yes I think people
need to be aware of what's going into
their body good or bad I guess if it's
an ingredient inside the food then yeah
anything that's inside the food should
be if a bag of cheetos said will alter
your DNA poorly maybe somebody wouldn't
want to eat those Cheetos that day all
that DNA and Cheetos just ruining it
course labeling food containing DNA is
pretty silly it's the stuff of life
contained in just about every morsel of
fruit vegetable grain or meat put into
your mouth but we ask this question of
locals in Venice California because food
science researchers out of the
University of Florida found that 80% of
Americans they polled favored mandatory
DNA labeling this tracks with the widely
held view that mandatory labeling of
genetically modified organisms is a good
idea which 84% of respondents to the
same poll believed to be true you effect
then that its natural state it I just
don't I can't believe that it's healthy
it's a very serious thing should start
messing with our food system and I think
it should really be thoroughly
researched there are studies you know
that show that over 25 years there
haven't really been conclusive links
showing that GMOs cause more disease or
you know are more harmful than other
crops so you know does that change your
mind at all or what would what would you
need to see in order to I've seen
documentaries there's like conspiracy
and they're all on Netflix in reality
humans have been genetically modifying
our food for centuries just with less
precise techniques GMO foods are no less
safe than their non GMO counterparts and
the fact is that GMOs have fed the world
thanks in large part to GMOs the amount
of land plowed by farmers increased by
only about 10 percent while we've grown
tripled the amount of food to feed a
doubling population it all raises a
serious question our science and
politics compatible do you think that
politicians care about science when
they're thinking about policy
no I don't think so especially on the
right wing a lot of people a lot of
politicians are really skeptical of
universities and stuff they think
they're indoctrinating people I do think
that there is misinformation and a lot
of misguided people particularly in the
right a lot of those people are can be
like very devoted Christians or that
kind of thing and they have a lot of
heavy religious beliefs that stem for
like the Bible and doubt and I'll be
killed or whatever
creationism food diets auto safety I
mean even gun control that's a science
it seems like the left side is a lot
more open it is true that fewer
conservatives and liberals believe in
things like the theory of evolution but
not by much Pew Research found that 30%
of Democrats deny evolution compared to
39 percent of Republicans when it comes
to other scientific matters the waters
are even muddier for instance Democrats
and Republicans believe in the false
link between vaccines and autism at
roughly equal levels our rate in
autoimmune disease is going up our rate
in autism is going up our rate in
diabetes is going up and I really do
believe that vaccines are the first step
if a virus comes back well you know what
we just have to evolve along with it so
if let's say smallpox came back no
vaccine you wouldn't you wouldn't
Backson it yourself if smallpox came
back
hood yeah not back sending myself and
it's largely Liberal Democratic
politicians pushing anti vaping laws
I've read only a couple things about how
it is hazardous or just as hazardous to
them to health as a smoking cigarettes I
think that vaping is shouldn't shouldn't
even be allowed because I think that in
the vaping you don't really know what
you wear or anything I've heard that
although vaping looks better they're
actually pretty they will have nicotine
and they will have like tar and
carcinogens is there is there any
scientific like proof that well like ii
can vaping like causes problems or
respiratory issues or anything public
health agencies estimate these
cigarettes to be around 95 percent safer
than conventional tobacco cigarettes and
there's evidence they help smokers quit
vaping products don't contain any
tobacco if the fda still wants to treat
them as tobacco products the big science
policy issue of the day though seems to
be global warming why do you think that
the right is more biased because donald
trump says that there's no global
warming
climate change and you know to actually
deny that that's real is pretty
ludicrous as a scientist there has been
a lot of objection climate change for
instance which has been pretty solid
scientific evidence for a while there's
pretty clear science on emissions and
that sort of thing I believe that anyone
who thinks that climate change isn't
real is a joke I went to an article a
few years ago and I can tell you climate
change is real 64% of Democrats believe
in man-made global warming while only 22
percent of Republicans do but when it
comes down to realistic solutions to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions
Democrats still aren't always
science-minded do you support
alternative energy sources like fracking
if they would reduce the amount of
greenhouse gases going into the
atmosphere I don't particularly think
fracking is a good thing I think it
causes your taking water from you know
really deep sources and they cause
earthquakes where places they shouldn't
be pumping stuff into the ground and
causing earthquakes and fissures and all
kinds of stuff if they can figure out
another technology that's like similar
or like works a similar way that's less
invasive on the environment totally I'd
be for it for sure I don't know if you
saw this but the EPA actually just came
out with with their years long study on
fracking and they found that there was
no systemic contamination of groundwater
or disease and the communities affected
so if you saw convincing data that
showed that what you maybe change your
mind on that is sure sure I think so I
mean you know again the sanctity of
certain environments is important to me
burning natural gas extracted through
fracking is cleaner than oil or gasoline
and far more economically viable than
non-nuclear renewable sources and it
emits half as much carbon dioxide less
than one-third the nitrogen oxides and
1% as much sulfur oxides as coal
combustion the ongoing switch from coal
to natural gas
generate electricity is a primary driver
of the reduction in u.s. greenhouse gas
emissions by half a billion tons over
the last decade according to the EPA the
US geological survey found that fracking
can cause extremely small earthquakes
but they are almost always too small to
be a safety concern and is more
concerned with the particular method of
wastewater disposal that can cause
larger earthquakes what do you think
about nuclear energy as
form of renewable energy it's again it's
got to be safe I'd be really worried
about having like giant nuclear plants
in California only because of what we
saw in Fukushima if I were worried about
people potentially dying like a
Chernobyl sort of a situation I would be
more concerned about that than I would
about not being able to go to Venice
City but you say the word nuclear and
everybody is absolutely terrified
because they think after Noble or with
Fukushima of radiation and like cause of
the universe only 45% of Democrats
support expanding the use of nuclear
energy as compared to 62% of Republicans
despite the fact that except for
Chernobyl not a single person including
nuclear workers has ever died due to a
commercial nuclear reactor incident if I
if I told you that since Chernobyl it
was zero in any commercial nuclear exit
world they're not even at Fukushima no
no people died at Fukushima yeah
interesting from the radioactive
releases that sort of thing so maybe
it's not Republicans who are dumber than
Democrats when it comes to science or
the other way around but that everyone
has blind spots when data based evidence
contradicts their political preferences
I think you see because all these topics
are very nuanced and very opinion based
and they really lead people to think all
our black or white answers like yes no
GMOs are bad this is bad this is bad
right so it's interesting to know these
sort
so many of these are like kind of gray
area questions